one of our favorite guests and he
interestingly enough not here to really
pitch much because you've been there and
done that Michael Chiklis yourself in
the hopper yeah I got a couple of films
in the can and a couple coming up and
something that I actually can't talk
about that it's like Fight Club yeah
it's pretty if it happens how many
people come up to you so what do you get
mostly when people come up to you to
talk about you know what actually I'm
really loved the fact that I get such a
mixed bag okay
I mean I I get everything from you know
it's clobberin time to you know hey the
Commission a lot of people from the
shield obviously the shield really
affected so many people and FX which by
the way got sold from from Fox to Disney
today this was pretty much you know FX
made their vault is a fantastic for
franchise okay what do I mean and that's
made it's it's lovely clobberin time why
not yeah but so you get you get the
shield more maybe more than the Commish
do you think or yeah probably probably
why do you think that the shield
resonated so much Michael well you know
it really it was a game changer you know
we broke through with you know basic
cable there wasn't anything I base a
cable when we broke through and it
really changed the whole landscape of
television at the time so we pushed the
cop shows on route to a different place
and at the same time made it made cable
a viable place to do original content so
it was an exciting incredible time and
you know Vic Mackey was in a you know an
iconic incredible character to play cuz
you know it's one of those fine lines
those tight rope sort of characters
between love and hate people you know
people wanted to love this guy but like
but the things that he does and that's
that's always a tricky line to play and
I'm sure I don't know if you heard but
your favorite Commissioner Roger Goodell
has signed one last contract extension
saying saying that this is his last one
there's a silver lining in every black
claw what you owe you Patriot fans would
you be willing to be the next
Commissioner of the National Football
League well the Commission well
certainly certainly if I was called upon
I would have to seriously consider it
especially for those numbers Wow
yeah I mean congratulations to him
that's that's wonderful and so suddenly
your first order of business would be
what do nobody looks at the footballs or
[Laughter]
right into the fact that that and I know
this is gonna sound weird but the
Patriots even know when to lose and last
week I'm actually thrilled that they
lost because it was an inconsequential
loss but I know because I know Tom that
Tom Brady hates to lose probably more
than he loves to win and when he loses
he gets mad and it's a mad and angry tom
brady is a is a formidable thing I mean
that guy he is laser-focused and he gets
motivated every year in every sport
there's a motivating turn there's a
there's a season altering turn a couple
of years ago was when we got beat by
Casey and you're moving on to Cincinnati
yeah well yeah and and everyone was
saying he's over already this week
people are saying oh there's the crack
the guys having an all-world year and
immediately he's but that's it that's it
Peyton Manning
he's watch it's gonna go like this now
and don't count Tom Brady out that's
that's no I know Lee I know and that's
why I asked Hines Ward last hour like
what do you think heart or heart
Steelers are excited to see what the
Patriots look like on Monday night
because they see what they can exploit I
understand Gronk wasn't there and
Gronk's gonna be back and that is a huge
difference maker yeah now but that said
like are they
looking at it thinking okay this is a
beatable team or they looking at it
saying all go I think they have to I
mean of course they're gonna look at
them as a beatable team because
everybody's beatable you know any given
Sunday it's true right yeah you know
this there's a lot of parity in the
league now and these teams can beat each
other then it that's when it comes down
to you know that's I always give the
Patriots an edge because it's not just
Tom Brady obviously it's Bill Belichick
you know and and his coaching staff and
these guys you can see them looking at
the other team through the first half
and what they're just they're assessing
every weakness in that team right and
they come back in the second half
usually exploiting those those
weaknesses and I have to say you know
obviously Tom had a bad game last week
he struggled and you can count on him to
struggle at least in one game in the
season if not two during the regular
season and Miami is usually the spot
where it's gonna take yeah he has these
places where he kind of notoriously dips
and Miami's one of them mm-hmm and then
he gets all Tom about it and gets mad I
just gave Michael Chiklis the Emmy Award
winning actor here on the Rich Eisen
show I just feel I don't know that if
Kenyan Drake did what he did
Le'Veon Bell is just gonna be off and
crackin yeah and that that would that
would be the one that concerns me more
than anything else
let's concern hatreds you know yeah that
would be the one thing I just don't know
who they're going to if they if they
have these matchup problems in the same
way that Adam GaSe was able to
coordinate Todd Haley's gonna be able to
do the same exactly what do you think
Pittsburgh has the same kind of pass
rush as Miami has well TJ watt into the
game himself last week it's true I mean
it's JJ Watt there's bud Dupree
that I mean they have the guys in the
middle you know listen I've never talked
about about the Patriots I just don't I
think it's sort of against our
collective Phillip philosophy at New
England it to to talk smack because we
know you can get beat really yeah
Englanders don't talk smack it's not me
not that my life crew of friends we know
not to do it that guy superstitious I'm
too superstitious client I think we melt
we know what the bad times are like yeah
like what I mean oh hang on a second
hold on wait vision is history you can
say that out loud
I mean oh I mean no I understand you're
talking about the Boro day it was 40
when the Red Sox won the first World
Series but my grandmother was the first
person on the phone with me don't know
last time these effing guys did this I
was one true story I was going recent
history and by recent I mean the last
two days it's true it's true that my
walking the planet was called it's true
that my daughters have a really really
whacked-out understanding of doing Lin
sports it's true but it's not that we
talk smack it's like look at the Super
Bowl you know you're down at the half 28
to 3 and you're like it's fine we'll
come back Mike you have a tremendous
amount of faith mount of faith and
that's where we don't panic and there's
no reason to talk smack because the
smack-talking is look at the trophy case
like so boisterous about it I'm just
like oh cool no you're just an [ __ ]
let me just retweet the meme of Brady
holding up we can see I said to Tom in
the locker room last June we were doing
the best buddies thing I said to him I
couldn't help but I sorry Tom I got to
tell you tell people is I said 48 you
know because she's talking about going
to 48 you know and he goes it's a goal
it's a goal I go good good everybody
asked tough goals it's great it's great
right I go but you know you have five he
goes I have another hand
now that is smack talk that is smack
talk
now Frank Pentangeli love Tom Brady to
say that and then of course if he
displayed at least 48 then he's got a
foot too let's take a 60-second break
come back we'll talk about the Stanton
news oh okay all right we'll talk about
that a bit more maybe we'll sneak in a
call since you're up up you say your
love doing sports talk radio I do let's
do it
back in 60 seconds with Michael Chiklis
here in the Rich Eisen show on when we
return a great old gen stat from last
night's Indiana Pacers lost to OKC big
Paul George moment last night that
sacked Michael Chiklis here on the Rich
Eisen show for another segment they boot
him and my favorite part about the
booing is their shot so they took of the
fans booing him a couple who were
wearing Indiana pacer Paul George
jerseys oh well booing him that's why
the rout of fanatic
yes fan okay so there you have it here's
a great old gen stat brought to you by M
drive the holiday seasons here increased
stress overeating lack of energy fewer
trips to the gym that's what the holiday
season means for most purchase M drive
at Walgreens Duane Reade vitamin shop
sprouts in GNC go to M drive now calm
and you put in the promo code rich and
you get 25% off your purchase refined
your prime with M drive okay here's the
old gen status you know these new G's
next gen stats you see during the
football games and the other guy I don't
understand them I like old gen stats
I like wins losses runs meet in or in
this case triple doubles okay III this I
can understand Russell Westbrook last
night thanks to his ninth triple-double
of the season 88th by the way of his
career it was since the calendar turned
from 2016 to 2017 his 35th triple-double
of the calendar year 2017
that is the most triple-doubles in a
calendar year in NBA history surpassing
the 34 that Oscar Robertson had in the
calendar year of 1961 Wow that's your
old gents down here on the ridge oh well
I asked you about a stat and you never
got back to you know what I asked you is
this true that every every team that
ever won the World Series during the
regular season scored 40% or more of
their runs with two outs yeah and I
think I sent you back like what yeah but
think about that if that stat is true
someone said that to me and I was like
that's for some reason that rings true
to me because that 40% of their runs are
in the clutch to out you know it's the
difference between a championship team
and one that isn't the the teams that
grind every out and and don't have that
dip so many teams just psychologically
they have two outs there's a letdown it
did where the grinding teams the teams
like you know the rest Astros I mean
your Red Sox were grinded four runs last
year man that's rind it
I mean absolute like yeah here's another
stat Stanton and judge combined last
year had three fewer home runs in the
Red Sox had for their entire team and
actually we're not no but but for the
first time in our history that's what we
used to be you know as a home run inning
team and I like that we play some small
ball I mean we could use a yeah but I'm
not happy about him joining the Yankees
obviously I mean that really upset let
me hit this here because I don't want to
hear the evil empire is back how is it
not back
no here yes unfortunately let's just
leave five dollars no no that's all
right rich face it when you watch the
Star Wars come on now sit there in the
audience going go Darth no I are you
root for Darth Vader you know I'm with
the force sir okay I like I like I like
the Jedi I'm rooting for the Jedi no no
ganged up on now how does it feel to
have the tide be even in all seriousness
the Yankees are able to afford Stanton
in the same way the Red Sox can the Red
Sox aren't like you no they're not John
Henry and how much money do the Yankees
spend hold on a second John haha
John Herrick Tom Werner who's making
Roseanne again okay is not true it's
true we spent we have the second largest
spend in in the league and so the reason
why though the Yankees can do this is
because judge is on his first contract
Sanchez on his first contract Gregorio
on his first a tremendous job building
this team there's no question what am I
supposed to like it yes you're supposed
no I hate I mean you know I liked last
year because there was a war at least
now see you know it tilts the unless we
make a great acquisition right we need a
bat big metaphor that we yes so you know
Ellsbury is available to understand
where the the evil empire thing happened
to is it's not just that they spend more
than everybody else and all of that it's
it's how they spent against us they
Steinbrenner my whole life
we bought was one of my heroes one of my
heroes you don't understand what it was
as a third baseman and a guy who loved
Wade Boggs to see him in pinstripes on a
horse that I nearly passed away that day
that killed me
yes rating the 96 World Series
so what is is they D targeted our most
beloved guys they add that you know the
Johnny Damon's may rest in peace and who
they love the most who's really
delivered for them by him and that's
what they've done and that's why we have
such a just a litte snot even loathing
it's luring it's like I got a make up a
new word even got you should I break the
news right now
now that Starlin Castro has been sent
for for for Stanton the Yankees have
just signed Dustin Pedroia to attend
your contract by the way I would quit
the show you could offer two billion
dollars would never do that
unfortunately feel like I'm blowing my
invite to your house to watch the
Patriots know you'll be surrounded
that's fine I'm surrounded in my own
household you know are you aware that my
children are being raised Patriots fans
are you aware that my my my wife is from
the New England area oh she was the Tom
Brady went to the finest school of
higher learning of the University of
Michigan and here I'll play this I did
this I played it only on on the podcast
I do with my wife by the way which you
were more than vitae to we'd love to
have you on okay he did it this week
with Hank Azaria's our guest I became
one of those dads who who videoed my son
crying over a sports loss I thought to
myself Susie when she first saw that she
goes oh that's a plus block on the Rich
Eisen show but she said I'm gonna do it
right now on a simulcast this was my son
upset that the Patriots were losing to
the Dolphins and he knew that they would
not be clinching the AFC East Division
oh I guess this is Cooper
[Music]
[Music]
yeah and then and then Sean mcdonoughs
voice person is enough to break your
heart I felt like that in 2004 they
weren't gonna clinch the division I felt
like that in 2004 watching you guys in
that season in July 2004 I was Yunior
slid across home plate and Don
Mattingly's 95 season ending the first
playoff series of Don Mattingly and only
playoff series of his career I snapped
the television off and I sat in silence
I didn't cry over that the last time I
cried over a sporting event was after
the Yankees lost the 1981 World Series
to the Dodgers and I knew Reggie Jackson
wasn't coming back and that was my
childhood hero and I cried that night
literally like my six-year-old did and I
was 11 the last time I helped someone
with you the last time I cried was 86
gets past Buckner or there was another
one this is another game you know no I
knew there was total collapse there I
just thought there's no way now that
we're done
Mike sure you were thanks for coming on
I love that you come anytime
please come back anytime certainly when
that that project that you can't talk
about right now like your own personal
fight clothing especially when I have
something to promote my house is yours
thanks but and bring T b12 the next time
okay bring your pug the next time
alright
when we come back I do believe somebody
associated with the Cheesecake spot that
I need to sign of eight-by-ten glossy
for is on a phone line I gotta leave
right now what's the clubhouse leader GZ
make always be rich may cheese okay
somebody called in saying best cheese
I've ever cut with back with more on the
Rich Eisen show in a moment the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience